today's next toolkit is my opinion live
from Shanghai University final moments
talking about canning independent sets
and coverings on the random regular
rifle Thanks
I would like snacks to organize for
inviting me here and for bringing
together this very wonderful workshop
and PLO from Sahib University openness
and economics and today I will talk
about counting independent sets and
counting Collings on random regular
paragraph this joint work with layouts
how linkable and the mole changes they
are my students and posters and who
stabbed left pointer that's actually so
similar result was independently
obtained by where I was the first
speaker and actually I we also bowler
every sleep long whereas talk and stuff
clumsier so best where my work is a kind
of application of this general approach
using this polymer model and the one
thing differential work from the
previous this computer the partition
function input for this possible is that
we actually not only using this ground
state but we using something like lost
class so it's a family of configurations
was there a single one the previous
talks you see that it's like red or all
right or blue or white is a kind of
grown States and some deviation from
that here it's not single still that we
talk about across state a current
cluster so here it's actually a comma
recipe how to design our community
approach first of all we identify
grass days for the problem then we we
define the neighborhoods of this grant
stays and prove that their summation is
that actually a good approximation of
the original counting problem so we
define a polymer model for each grant
state to replicate the deviation from is
grown States and they we prove that
actually this polymer model is a good
approximation then we verify this KP
condition for the polymer model which we
are giving as I applied Haskell problem
okay that's a common recipe for Poisson
as a to problem were present in this
talk price
yeah yeah yeah this is a picture we're
so so this is a space we're gonna count
or a kind of partitioning function with
town we want to compute then we want to
identify some grants tastes so it is a
family of stairs and they may overlap
with each other and then we define a
neighborhood of these blown states and
we won't prove that actually we summing
over all these neighborhoods across
states they will give a good
approximation of that the total set
which means that the configuration
outside all the other neighborhoods are
very small and also the intersection of
this this grant state background caste
last more so we don't need a double
count too much okay that's the same one
true and then I want to get aside for
each grants there's a groan caster and
its neighborhood we have to find a
polymer model and to show that this
problem would actually say about this KP
condition okay let's start with okay
there was the mai tai as I might I
suggest I'm the accounting the back
independent sets and color Li for random
regular paper graph actually we don't
really use too much property about this
line random lag loop applause we only
use the expansion property of this just
I mean your graph so one expansion
properties that when the there's a set
2d from left side or right side is more
enough then the expansion is its large
so this is so this expansion property is
a unique repair to parameter alpha and a
beta you deliberate has a large or small
and another property called curly
properties with kind of a extreme of the
expansion problem which says that as
long as the set is large enough its
enable almost covers outside except a
small fractional okay it's easy to prove
that when the degree Delta is large
enough a random Delta landgraf
almost surely has this kind of good
property I did not specify the that
element alpha beta
as Santa at how they relate to the
particulate data because we've actually
different parameter for different
problem but it's a lovely idea is that
this alpha is well it's more an S alpha
s and that has more when there is a
approach infinity C approach 0 and beta
is close with the odd part could be
linear or as a linear in their tower as
a like a square root of their tossing
like that okay that's that's the only
thing we used for random graph ok start
with counting independent sets so
cutting the pass tests for better graph
is actually a very important problem in
the field of a plasma counting
it is conduct to be how intermediate
complexity is not may not have pulling
up it has or furiously not has had as
empty hynek's okay so it also plays an
important role in the classification
because many other problems proved to be
B is hard or B is equivalent problem
from the urban side with Jimmy Bedoya
he proves that probably obtained f it
has for for the B is problem when
actually one-sided degrees is bounded by
5 we don't have any any little comfort I
decide for this particular problem for P
is a molecule random regular paragraph
it's also important to reason why is
that it's easy to show that same same
sees of slow mixing when theater is
supreme large large or equal to say X is
already slow mixing the other thing is
that user user Hanna proof for the for
the independence at actually this random
rock blue back cross is that important
gadget
so these are some penguins
okay now let's let's follow the recipe
to to give a urban for that okay for
this indepence that problem we actually
identify to run the cluster
first class is that this indepen set
which intelligent using from the left
side if this set is entirely to using
films left sides they are all always
independent okay because a paragraph or
the in the passage which are entirely
choosing from the
sighs yeah or so each cluster contains
two to the many different independence a
you're not single in assessment yeah
family means and not mean we define a
neighborhood of these two cluster things
that is if in the past set is almost
choosing from one side say if it is
really intersection with the left
started with a very small fraction of
nose because the neighborhood for this I
and similarly qualifier are okay now the
ideas that we're gonna show that there's
something over the indepence s you I am
I
and ah it's a good really good
approximation sir so all the independent
says that's actually quite easy to prove
well firstly that one sure that the
intersection of these two settings were
small so we don't really double count
too much and this is because what for
indepence said choosing from the
intersection
it actually takes at most alpha nodes
from each side then we can count the
number all possible such in dependencies
and choose alpha and square and if this
alpha is not enough this number is very
small comparing two through two then you
go to 12 and is the size of the cluster
thank you
so this is saying that their
intersection is very small and we also
show that the independence at which all
sides both set is also very small that's
also quite is it sure we using this this
coupling property so if the unit instead
takes sm knows from one side it will
covers almost all the other side so from
that side as we can take our other nose
so it's belong to this family so if it's
not it belong to this family means that
it can take at most s denotes from both
side
okay given that we can also countable or
possible success and we with s more
enough this number is exponentially
small compared to put so now we we can
compute the size of IAO and the computer
size of our and the summary map which is
a good approximation we define a polymer
border for one same as actually a
symmetric let's recall that this is the
definition for IR so so it's a it's a
deviation
it's a this is not a single single
computer issue so activation forms that
we knew that it's because in this
cluster we want to choose in the entire
subset from the best side
but have sides here all the nodes
through diplomacy left sides kind of
deviation from the wrong class though
right so well each in the past said in
this set some so the connected
components of the debates to the nodes
which is the intersected section of the
interstate with the left side and this
kind of other points for the for the for
the polymer and but we defined as in the
previous talk this this polymer is a
family of connected component but here
we have to defy this connection with
respect to G 2 rather than G laalili
laalili graph V if this if the two
attacks are actually
with in distance - you already class
then we say they say are connected we
define the connected components in that
sense otherwise we cannot really cover a
little problem from this polymer so I
will give a picture then we can define
this gamma star to denote order or the
possible polymer and this this
compatibility or poly modifier similarly
but the possibilities back to t2 and
this distance you actually have the
properties at two comparable poly mode I
don't share any neighbors it's actually
equivalent definition they are connect
yeah I mean with putting distance
touches in Y in this graph and we using
this s s gamma star to denote or process
of compatible polymers so let's give a
give a picture so so here this is the
left side this is a sign and most of the
the nose choosing these films are what
have sine of it's it's omitted here and
some nodes are choosing from the left
hand side so as these are the nose which
was inflamed left and and say since I
set the divisions from the long stays
then we actually loops him using the
connect connect components these three
nodes are connect energy too because
this year some may about together and
this is a singleton and assessing good
so for this it be hopefully to the
polymers okay now we want to define the
the weights of the polymer right like in
the previous pip so what is the meaning
of the voice of a polymer basically the
music once your your your treating some
what has from left side it we have
consequence that you cannot no longer
choose any of his neighbor right so
basically for each neighbor
previously it has two options occupied
or not occupied no you only have one
more option which is not occupied so
this is one over to basically
it's a loose your effect bad better
better better facts that you are to
Samsung were texting the left has
actually so this is a weight function
this is these just a form of elbow I
think within with the new algorithm as
president in the police talk we actually
can ignore that iPad just to use the S
wah but previously we are using this say
loveliness and this this view this
Easter is a form available we want to
show that the partition function is
really with respect to Z up to some
point slightly above once and we can
compute the partition function at the
point Z equal to one okay so now we with
this knows with these weights we can
define the partition function for the
polymer which is the exactly same with
in the previous talk this is summing
over all the a collection of compatible
polymers and for each each collection we
take this product of order or the
polymer in that collect in the set and
I'll pause there weights
and the relation here is that by
choosing these weights in this way this
size the size of this il is exactly
equal to 2 to the N times this this
partition function of the over the
polymer but with the global consumes
that this satisfies the total size of
the polymer is not larger than alpha and
because this is a constraint for the IAO
given that everything else is just a
one-to-one correspondence so this this
size is attached to this partition
function but with the global cost you
okay so we don't really like this global
country and because there's a sale of a
polymer at each country without our
global costume so one thing we are sure
is that you can actually safely just
just slow away this country and this is
still put approximation because the
reason is that this weight function is
of can look exponentially decay because
this pay dies expense you assume that so
we can because the Scott is this global
country just to compute as a partition
function for the polymer models it's
also a good approximation for there was
a size we want to compute
no the only thing we have left to verify
is a KP condition and it's let's recall
this this is a machine so we are Sam for
a particular given polymer gamma star we
sum over all the incompatible polymer
gamma with this quantity and we're going
to bond that as by the size of this
gamma star so in this summation we
wanted to in mute enumerate all possible
polymers which is incompatible with
gamma star
so we basically this this gamma must be
either intersect with gamma star or
shear some neighbor with him so
basically we enumerated our vertex which
is either in this polymer or its
neighbor so there's as a polymer gamma
must contain at least one vertex from is
that ok ouch then we enumerate his a
integer care which will respond
represents the size of the polymer gamma
then we finally enumerate all the
possible polymer gamma containing this
vertex V and will cite okay and this is
a kind of a way to ponder this this
summation so here is the possible number
of e's so it's a because this the
corresponding patata
it's square and this is something where
this part is all possible connect
component connect components of the
graph containing V and this case that's
this ek because we are just summing over
always okay and they stood to the minus
beta K is a waste funky up one other bit
funky this is easy so we had some kind
of like splashy now by choosing this
because since this beta is a is a chloe
function with delta something like
in your square root of their tassel this
is exponentially mahtim so by choosing
they are large enough we can make this
this one small enough even clear this
del square in the form and everything is
less than equal to the size of the gamma
star which is requirement for this
cubicle issue on its detail here but
it's everything is quite clear
now with that we can actually stick to
the parameter let and it proved that if
this data is logical to 53 there's AF
PETA's for this bad part in the past
eight for almost every day at regular
bagra and we can also extend this result
for the helical model with parameter
lambda then as well as this this data is
large enough is efficient large not
constant and also this parameter lambda
is large large or equal to this value
basically if be a fixed lambda we can
choose Delta large enough to to satisfy
this inequality there's a FB toss to
compute because that if there are if you
know a little probe B is problem if
there is it based or equal to five you
actually have a cute ass back on the kit
also for the latest case if lambda is
less or equal to this quantity this is
almost like a in order one over the
other
we have a absolute a speculation the key
then our new services that if lambda is
large enough for is value enough
actually we also have a cheetah's but
something in the middle is missing how
about from there are some sticks to 52
will happen I mean we can current
because for sure to mean optimatus but
it's not likely become popular all the
way to six I think that's not something
in the middle they are missing if you
are choosing a uniform emptily
SN clear yeah we actually about this GM
similar we don't know yet
okay this finishes a indepence that part
now let's count coloring okay coloring
is also another kind of extensively
studied the problem music in the earlier
a plasma county across many poseur with
a general graph known as a bad path by
putting a graph we have to make this
qslide year at least logic then the must
agree to make sure that they exist
q coloring and so all the studies from
there but but for pepper graph it's very
different because for any backpack graph
at hand for any qslide or equal to to
co-exist of q color little background
and it was also known that [ __ ] in cook
q coloring on that graph is actually be
is hard but I think it's not known to be
PS ik equivalent yeah that's a situation
okay but not sure that when the sticker
is large enough you can actually count
dorkula lean on random that paragraph
okay now photo actually exactly the same
that's the paper is more money more of
the way because coloring is more
complicating independent okay so here
now first step is identify some grown
clusters what is coming
so here it's actually the gross clusters
are indexed pair something of the
coloring
so the crosses is that pair fixed X
which is a subset of all possible colors
we actually color only see from the left
side by a color choosing from X or and
the other right hand side was actually
color flomax complement of X so it was
everything every choice of it's from
these families their proper coloring
because we are actually different colors
flow gives said move even start we kind
of well give put back across this is
also always a proper coloring so we also
defines that kind of the neighbors of
this of see school and class which is
which means that the coloring is very
close to that meaning that they were
seen from this this grand cluster is
responded about alpha n which means that
there's a the nose in the left side
which is not colored by
class from X is plus the number of notes
in the right hand side which colored by
the collage flomax are small and in
particular it's easy to see that if this
X is close to the size of X is closed to
traffic you see actually gives the
largest cluster and as their size is
computed that is true for all the city
oh here's some some effects some simple
effects respect I say that if a to
integer a and B the summation is less
than equal to Q minus 1 so in any any
possible is a to the N times P to the N
is expanding small compared to this
quantity and also if they are summing up
to Q but they are not close enough they
are not half half if they are difference
is larger than 1 so this this quantities
or also kind of exponential is small
okay
so now even clues that summing over all
these possible neighborhoods of the
clusters gives a good approximation of
the possible coloring the first thing my
child shows that the intersection of
these clusters are very very
exponentially small this is easy to see
because for CX and CY then most of the
left hand knows that a colored bad color
from the intersection of x and a y and
scientist from the intersection of x bar
and y bar say if X is not equal to Y see
there are some some something that you
in the symmetric difference and so this
two number is somewhat the summation of
these two numbers is at most humor as
well and the caymans the mismatch facts
we showed a number of such such coloring
is expansion small compared to the size
okay and we also want to show that the
coloring outside all the neighborhoods
of this class statistically much more
then we using the the coupling property
and we can show that the kind of at most
humans wow colors are used by at least
Esther nose and then we choosing this s
more enough
that's an apple callus this is that is
exponential we can further show as I
already mentioned that we only needed to
summon all the broadcast with egg with
the size X is approximately half of and
because anything else and also better
symmetry of this color Li CX and CY same
size as long as the size of X and a wire
same because they are symmetry on top so
basically yeah it's end up with a very
very simple algorithm for even even Q
you only need two computer the sides for
this particular cluster which is
choosing to the colors from 1 to 1/2 Q
from left side and have Q plus 1 through
Q will oppose black high side with you
then times this other possibility Q
juice half Q is a good approximation and
for all Q is slightly plain but similar
no we only show that this granite
clusters and as your neighbors have a is
a good approximation for the set of all
proper coloring and we did not be
defines the polymer model which is the
president's the deviation from this this
grant class says so as estimation is
also easy to define basically all the
nodes which not colored as what you
expect him okay so basically the nodes
from the left side which not colored
there's a color from X and also those
from the right has I live is not colored
that colors from X bar similarly we also
defines a polymer model as a connect
components for this deviated nose but
also business back up to this g2 also
and think everything else is similar
now here is a example this is like a
three color line and yeah we are looking
at his class he were or the left hand
side is colored green red and all the
rehearsals notes are colored by blue and
a yellow so says since that deviated
nose because this should be colored red
bicycle yellow and Cooling here as he
should not be colored by reliable since
okay then we also fuzzy deviated nose we
we I mean connected components with
respect to G to this this who knows I
actually connected by G - because she's
a she some neighbors also the
neighborhoods outside is this polymer so
it is the here is another another
polymer another similarly we define the
way of the polymer which will replace
the kind of defect this polymer have to
his neighbor basically like for we can
make actually product tech block over
all the neighbors of this polymer as you
because this knows since it connects to
attack seems either polymer which is
color yellow previously this this knows
have to choice which is wise yellow
white cooling but no it's only held one
choice so it will contribute effect of
like one or two six and this polymer
partition function and this relation is
the same also with this global extreme
and that we can also safely
discard this global country due to the
fact that is this weight of polymer is
this is and this is expecially care or
if this this the the total size is large
this number is good enough okay and
basically due to the same user and you
can verify this KP condition almost
identical me except a BIA with a
different decay rate what is different
here for the for the independence that
once you you have the support for poly
more everything's fixed but here you
know accepts the support of the polymer
you also need to enumerate all possible
colony on this what hex and so I have a
additional fact Q to the K here we
should have found all that anyway since
this beta closed as a functional there
at how we can always choose the
ethically large enough to make this
small enough to even hardest at school
very very similar philosophy by if we
want you to set all the parameter
classes they are some essential okay
that is we can clue that for any any Q
which is large or equal to three
actually for two it's exactly exactly
cutting continued algorithm so for if
data is large enough as a function of Q
here this should be up some polynomial Q
there's a any a few tasks for counting
the Q kind of almost every day at her
regular paragraph some open questions
wise try to close the gap as I said I
think the a point can be can be further
optimized by some more careful analyst
but it's unlikely that it can be putting
all the way down to the
to the uniqueness I mean mm of this
class a few tasks for collecting the
cake so I don't know this is to the back
country market I just open Cassie I
don't know yeah I don't know I would I
would I guess yes but I but it's really
quite some new new technique and well
another another open deductions that try
to up to apply this this new approach to
add a counting problem in particular you
can try since I just piss hard problems
or the problem is slow mixing MCMC
basically it's really have a kind of
opposite affected sometimes slow mixing
we actually can help us to decompose
that into different from classes and
using this polymer okay that's all thank
you I think in our paper we get like qq2
the Tensei inverse papers we actually
have bad luck you to the Q square Q
square yeah should be cure okay yeah
[Music]
does the method work at all if they're a
tiny number of edges inside the what
should be if you just make a ref sliding
on bipartite the tiny number of edges
inside each part it's really depend on
the model Rises it's a whole tiny and if
it's really tiny I think slow but yeah
let's say we have this or we choose the
wrong stage we also for privatized by
the same fraction versus chosen right
now when you're shooting is someone 0 0
1
but these are not so the maximum rate if
you Franco by the fraction versus chosen
yeah this actually something in my mind
I think it's towards a can two attacks
the middle yeah by fascist but it's it's
it's complicated because once I mean you
choose young Gwang cluster which is not
in Toledo and wha then it's not not
uniform the weight function is is it
hard to Defiance like yeah
particularly they should be the same for
every ground so black charcoal of the
Sun should be the same I guess
what are you saying but you try to some
symmetry no protocol I believe that the
first if we don't consider any cycle
then I guess it will simply give the
better approximation and then I guess if
we know that number of four side for six
I could it cycling and so on then it
gives a lot of improvement I guess even
a finite number of the cypress tree that
you see with a poplar tree or out of ten
the number of independency and then you
if you want really good approximation I
guess you really have to go up till look
at results using second moment method
that actually is showing exactly what
you're saying
small subgraph conditioning would say as
you just want up 1 plus epsilon for
constant epsilon it's
until the wide open problems the one
that this was asking yeah
their results known on the growth
condition for sharpest
baby so you said that this chart is
random regular graphs for important
gadgets in artists or this hardness for
many problems so that your empty hand I
suppose it will be also beside I mean
for that and so suppose that that the
answer is yes to the question you need a
little for every day out there you can
do it what kind of consequences we talk
to you see no consequences yeah
basically in that in the cat's eyes they
also showings as this the behavior of
this is quite regular and using the
factor to to prove the height so even if
this is easier it's not have a
consequence it takes place hardly
speed-up you just don't have that
expansion right like you have extension
within the gadget that then you connect
the terminals in a really non expanding
way no this is just a gadget not
interpret and is a the Highness plums
are at the other on a path so force a to
count the number of scheduled match
yeah that's that's a question I don't
know yeah I see interesting I mean
because this table match you don't have
a different structure and it's not even
clear clear how to define expansion or
random a stable matching yeah I think
that's certainly one word interesting
problem because it's heavily different
flavor and yeah
in Christmas
okay we have a longer break until 11:25